what I want to do in this video is a
fairly straightforward primer on
perimeter and area perimeter and I'll do
perimeter here on the left and I'll do
area here on the right and you're
probably pretty familiar with these
concepts but we'll revisit it just in
case you are not perimeter is
essentially the distance to go around
something or if you were to put a fence
around something if you were to measure
if you were to if you were to put a tape
around a figure how long that tape would
be so for example let's say I have a
rectangle let's say I have a rectangle
and a rectangle is a figure that has
four sides and four right angles so this
is a rectangle right here I have one two
three four right angles and it has four
sides and the opposite sides are equal
in length so that side is going to be
equal in length to that side and that
side is equal to length to that side and
maybe I'll label the points a b c and d
and let's say we know the following we
know that a b is equal to seven and we
know that bc we know that bc is equal to
5 and we want to know what is the
perimeter of ABCD so let me write down
the perimeter perimeter of rectangle a b
c d is just going to be equal to the sum
of the lengths of the sides if i were to
build a fence this was like a a plot of
land i would just have to measure how
long is this side right over here well
we already know that's seven in this
color so it's that side right over there
is of length seven so it'll be seven
plus this length over here which is
going to be five they tell us that bc is
five plus five plus DC is going to be
the same length as a b which is going to
be seven again so plus seven and then
finally da or a d however you want to
call it it's going to be the same length
as bc which is five again so plus five
again so you have 7 plus 5 is 12 plus 7
plus 5 is 12 again so you're going to
have an area perimeter you're going to
have a perimeter
of 24 and you could go the other way
around let's say that you have a let's
say that you have a square which is a
special case of a rectangle a square has
four four sides and four right angles
and all of the sides are equal so let me
draw a square here so let me draw a
square my best attempt so this is a B C
D and we're going to tell us tell
ourselves that this right here is a
square and let's say that this Square
has a perimeter so square has a
perimeter perimeter of 36 so given that
what is the length of each of the sides
well all the sides are going to have the
same length let's call them X so if that
if a B is X then VC is X then DC is X
and ad is X all of the sides are
congruent all of these segments are
congruent they all have the same measure
we call that X so if we want to figure
out the perimeter here it'll just be X
plus X plus X plus X or for X let me
write that X plus X plus X plus X which
is equal to 4x which is going to be
equal to 36 that gave us that in the
problem and to solve this for x
something is 36 you could solve that
probably in your head but we could
divide both sides by 4 and you get X is
equal to 9 X is equal to 9 so this is a
9 by 9 square this this width is 9 this
is 9 and then the height right over here
is also 9 so that is perimeter area is
kind of a measure of how much how much
space does this thing take up in two
dimensions and one way to think about
area is if I have a if I have a 1 by 1
square so this is a 1 by 1 square and
i'ts when I say 1 by what it means you
only have to specify two dimensions for
a square a rectangle because the other
two are going to be the same so for
example you could call this a 5x7
rectangle because that immediately tells
you okay this side is 5 and that side is
5 this side is 7 and that side is 7 and
4 square you could say it's a 1x1 square
because that specifies all of the sides
you could really say for a square
square where on one side is one then
really all the sides are going to be one
so this is a one by one one by one
square and so you can view the area of
any figure as how many 1 by 1 squares
can you fit on that figure so for
example if we were going back to this
this rectangle right here and I want to
find out the area of this rectangle and
the notation we can use for area is put
something in brackets so the area of
rectangle ABCD a b c d is equal to the
number of 1 by 1 squares we can fit on
this rectangle so let's try to do that
just manually I think you already might
get a sense of how to do it a little bit
quicker but let's put a bunch of one by
one so let's see we have 5 1 by 1
squares this way and 7 this way so I'm
gonna try my best to draw it neatly so
that's 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then 7 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 so going along one of the sides if
we just go along one of the sides like
this you could put seven just along one
side just like that and then over here
how many can we to see we see that's one
row that's two rows two rows then we
have three rows and then four rows and
then five rows 1 2 3 4 5 and that makes
sense because this is 1 1 1 1 1 should
add up to 5 these are 1 1 1 1 1 1 1
should add up to 7 yep they're 7 so this
is 5 by 7 and then you could actually
count these and this is kind of
straightforward multiplication if you
wanted to know the total number of cubes
here you could count it or you'd say
well look I 5 rows 7 columns I'm going
to have 35 not adjusted cube squares I
have 5 squares in this direction 7 in
this direction so I'm going to have 35
total squares so the area of this figure
right over here is is 35 and so the
general method you could just say well
I'm just going to take one of the
dimensions and multiply it by the other
dimension so if I have so if I have a if
I have a
rectangle let's say the rectangle is 1/2
by 1/2 by 2 those are its dimensions
well you can just multiply it you say
1/2 times 2 the area here is going to be
1 and you might tell me what is 1/2 mean
what means in this dimension I can only
fit half I can only fit half of a I can
only fit half of a 1x1 square so if I
want to do the whole 1 by 1 square it's
a little distorted here it would look
like that so I'm only doing half of one
I'm doing another half of one just like
that and so this when you add this guy
and this guy together you are going to
get a whole one now what about area of a
square well the square is just a special
case where the length and the width are
the same so if I have a square let me
draw a square here and let's call that X
Y Z I don't know let's make this s and
let's say I wanted to find the area and
let's say I know one side over here is 2
so X s is equal to 2 and I want to find
the area of X Y Z s so once again I use
the brackets to specify the area of this
of this figure of this polygon right
here the square and we know it's a
square we know all the sides are equal
well it's a special case of a rectangle
where we would multiply the length times
the width we know that they're the same
thing if this is 2 then this is going to
be 2 so you just multiply 2 times 2 or
if you want to think of it you square it
which is where the word comes from
squaring something so you multiply 2
times 2 2 times 2 which is equal to 2
squared that's where the word comes from
finding the area of a square which is
equal to which is equal to 4 and you can
see that you can easily fit you could
easily fit 4 1 by 1 squares on this 2 by
2 square